me
good finally
guard
seung wan hwan noresore apollo misae
ame
nanoha
quick
[music]
[applause]
Killian's already out of this world yeah
[music]
yeah
Music]
[Applause]
This is a question of chemistry Tell me if you can revive other Lillian songs with your power
es Echo-chan I'll heal you there
No, I can't
Terurun There's only one thing I can politely promise to you
Only this last song I'll protect without fail With
the power of science
You're clumsy too You'll
soon find out You
can't lie to your chin I
believe you  You know
, I'm going
to fall in love with you Seriously,
don't do that.
The [music]
transaction system
will be your strategy
ah ah ah